[Music]
[Applause]
man he's fallen on Hard Times Jim
Boeheim Hall of Fame head coach and now
he's relegated to being in our bracket
challenge a celebrity bracket Challenge
and right now he's he's in second place
but uh oh he's got Duke winning it all
whereas yeah Marvin prince who never
played basketball never coached
basketball and he is a uh he's got UConn
winning it all and uh he's he's winning
yes he is yes he is sometimes you you
can know too much about basketball I
think when you fill out these brackets
and he said this year was really hard
doesn't matter what you know I'm
surprised I mean there must what is
there four people in this contest is
that why I'm second because
I'm shocked uh you know it's really this
has been this craziest tournament we now
have balance you know we've said that
for years but then always there's two
number ones or three number ones in the
finals not anymore it's uh it's really
uh equal platforms for everybody and it
might be a good thing but I know one
thing I'd rather watch the women's teams
play than the men's right now watching
uh Caitlyn Clark from Iowa I mean that I
think that was probably the most
exciting player that I've seen in the
final four and either tournament uh in a
long time I I what an impressive player
you know rarely do you have a great
scorer who's the best passer in America
as well but I mean unbelievable what she
did and uh you know it's funny because I
was coming back until I walk in the
hotel and this little short guy comes up
to me and says great career and
everything and I realized it was the
point guard from Kansas State and
he is small I mean
they say five eight I'm I'm not sure but
he was one of the best pastors I've seen
for a point guard at all I mean the
imagination of his past but Caitlyn
Clark she's this unbelievable kind of
player I had seen her a little bit
during the year but sometimes you think
well can they do that in this tournament
against you know South Carolina against
LSU amazing amazing player how do you
when you know how a game is being called
because that game was it felt like it
was physical but they were calling Ticky
tack phones how do you as a coach
adjust
it's hard I mean the players have to win
jobs you know when they start calling
Things Early you know is a as a coach I
really like it when they call stuff
early and kind of get the physicality
out of the game because I think we have
too much of it but I I watch in the two
games you know Caitlin Clark didn't
really get any favors I didn't think in
the in the two games I saw I mean there
was a lot of
no calls that I thought were what was
that but uh you know at the end of the
day you just adjust and you play and the
officials don't decide the game I mean
if it's the last play of the game like
in one game we saw then then the kid
decided but over the course of the game
you're gonna get those calls
close
Yukon when UConn is in a final four
championship game UConn wins so if we go
back to 1999
you know they win championships but we
somehow don't include them in with
Kansas and Kentucky and Duke and UCLA
why aren't they considered maybe a blue
blood nationally
well the one thing I know Jim Calhoun's
one of the best coaches I've ever
coached against and I've been lucky to
coach against a lot
and I think he's hard to like sometimes
the media doesn't like him it's kind of
like me they don't like me because you
might a little bit but the rest you know
but I I think because of that
personality I I don't think Jim gets the
credit you have to understand it went
three at Connecticut this is you know
this was a Yankee conference school
before he took over
you know to win at Kansas to win it
through to when it can tell you it's
that easy I mean it's not easy for
anybody but you got a heck of a lot
better chance to get the kind of players
you need at those schools to win and so
what Jim did and you know now what
Danny's done
um
those are big time coaching moves this
is not a blue bun but they've made
themselves into that and Jim didn't get
nearly enough credit when you asked
somebody who the best five coaches Jim
Calhoun's not mentioned you know you'll
go sushefski you go south you go uh you
know Roy Williams you know you know a
lot of places
and Jim's not mentioned he is I mean he
is one of the he may be better you know
than than those guys for what he did
where he did it and I don't think he's
gotten the credit when he got there he
won and uh it's it's not easy to do any
of that stuff and Danny has done a
unbelievable job
um they clearly have the best team and
uh you you know usually at this stage uh
the best team will win sometimes the
best team doesn't get here but usually
at this stage the best team will win I
like San Diego State they play hard
they're really good defensively we
played them two years ago same guys and
they're much better much more physical
but it'll be it'll be a mountain to
climb for them to to beat Connecticut
we're talking to Jim Boeheim the former
Syracuse head coach I was wondering
about this now coach I heard Bruce Pearl
talk about this why recruit that kid out
of high school
spend a couple of years and maybe you're
getting for one year why not just wait
and do what UConn did just bring in all
these players even Kim Mulkey at LSU
bring in all these players well the
success has been there with multiple
teams I'm not going to go through this I
get in trouble I want to do that but the
transfer portal nil
change college basketball you look at
teams that our league went from the
bottom to the top in one year and
you get veterans seniors 23 years old I
don't care how good the freshmen are and
the other thing we're bringing in
freshmen
if you bring in three or four they don't
play a lot because they're freshmen
they're leaving so you lose it doesn't
do you any good to play them because you
lose them so I mean we recruit freshmen
I think you should be professional but
you better have porno guys and
especially when you get down a spot or
two you have to plug somebody in those
spots it's not always that easy remember
about eight 600 to the 1600 didn't get a
scholarship report and about half the
players that did get scholarships in the
portal over half did worse where they
transferred to so the portal is not an
automatic
it's you gotta get the right portal it's
just like you gotta get the right fresh
you gotta get the right portal guy who
fits your program who can if he's moving
up you know can move up some guys lower
level they don't do so well when they
move up to a higher level so it's a
tricky difficult thing but it's what
college basketball is now being in the
nil game in the transfer portal and you
know I've talked to a lot of people
about this and there is no solution you
know forget Congress they you know
they're having trouble debating you know
where they put the toilets down there
you know some days so we're not going to
get a solution there we have to find a
solution and there really isn't one
because the players Supreme Court
players can get whatever they want
whatever you can't limit it and the
boosters are involved and agents are
about so
hey you're a young coach you figure it
out just like every other problem in the
history of this board this is the
biggest one that I've seen and you're
out of it and I'm out of it and not
unhappy about that but uh hey did you
see the NBA with this new agreement
collective bargaining agreement it looks
like the one and done is going to stay
in college basketball yeah I was
everything I don't listen to everything
it's supposed to happen you know
I don't think they want young players I
don't think they ever have but
I think it's good for some guys just go
but
I don't think it changes anything really
um you know if you get the best freshman
you know they can play right away and
you're okay
but there's a few of those how many of
those after 20 maybe I don't know
um it's a small number
but you know we can't react to the NBA
what they do what we we have to figure
out a way that there's so many things
that could happen
all these young guys that do go after a
year you know there should there used to
be a mechanism where it was actually a
rule was proposed
they don't make it let them come back to
college
and it was well they got paid well now
everybody's getting paid so if a whole
bunch of young guys go out they see what
happened and there's a big number they
see pretty quickly yeah I'm I'm gonna
have to play in East you know Bavaria
someplace maybe I should go to college
let them come back
that's a
those are good players those are really
good college players let's let them come
back and go to college I mean it's it's
something that was proposed in the past
other sports have done it I I think it's
something that could happen but you know
now that I have nothing to do I can
think of all this stuff
and you should go to Mike Shashi you
should go to Roy Williams you should go
to some coaches right been there right
recently
ask them for their input you know you
have basketball team members and and you
know they're they're trying I know a
couple guys
they're not basketball people
talk to basketball people you know you
get the seating
it's okay to consider the whole season
for example for getting in the
tournament I understand that but if
you're playing in November winning and
you're playing in March and losing four
or five games in a row you're not the
high seated team you're just not you're
you you you you you can actually base
your seating on how a team's playing the
last 10 games you know if you don't want
to eliminate somebody from the
tournament because they lose six games
seven games out of ten all right I'll go
with that November is important but when
you come to see your team
it's how they're playing right now
that's important and I worry
before the Atlantic loses their
tournament they're not out they're not
in the tournament and they
um they certainly were the should have
won the other night could have easily
and they wouldn't be here
and you look a couple of the NIT teams
they're really good
so there's so much balance now it didn't
it used to be they used to say it's
balanced but then those teams again
trying to beat like 20 or 30. it's just
not the case anymore teams are good they
deserve a chance to play it's easy to
expand the tournament you play it you
have a play in sight right now
hasn't diluted the tournament helped the
tournament we got there through the play
in site one year so you have three
play-in sites you get another 12 teams
in just like that and you do it at the
site where the tournament is that
weekend now the team that wins it the
two teams that win it don't have to
travel they're right there
and it's easy and you really pick up
I mean there's always going to be
somebody that could get in but you'd get
that those nit teams that were really
good you get them in the tournament and
it doesn't cost anything it doesn't
dilute anything because after one game
everybody's it's not good it's gone
anyway so it's something they should do
but we'll see what happens but uh
the game is a great game I mean the
balance is there and that's good for
fans good for spectators see that happen
my team can get there
Whoever thought two teams for Florida
would be in the final four
years ago Whoever thought Alabama would
be good in basketball years ago and
anybody can anybody can get their uh
Blue Bloods still gonna get through
sometimes but it's it's hard it's harder
now for sure I mean you look at the top
two three teams in the country this year
Kansas Purdue
they're really good they couldn't get by
around here too you know it's just the
way college basketball is I mean when
you are number one seed before you won
you won your second game then you
started thinking about the tournament
you know it's not the case anymore
it looks like you're getting more hair I
mean you seem like you got better color
and I mean you know I think I think
retirements treating you well it's
probably your eyes you're probably
getting a little bit that's true that's
true need a little better glass I think
you're I think your wife is praying that
she gets worse eyesight then
she's going to see her number one son in
Czech Republic today she hasn't seen him
in seven months if it was me she would
not even be packed yet she wouldn't even
be we're ready to go to the airport like
four hours ahead of time she's going to
see Jimmy yeah if it was me over there
she would probably be sending me a
letter or something you know maybe maybe
I don't know sure that she'd do that but
hey you know I had an unbelievable run I
I never thought it would happen it's
just like you you never thought you'd be
doing this great things for so long you
thought you'd be pumping gas or
something I know that but anyway well
yeah hopefully I never fall prey to the
the only thing I'm doing is a celebrity
bracket Challenge on a radio show so if
I get that low then I've been offered
four jobs in the media since have you
really in four weeks so how tough can it
be how tough can it be I've never worked
in the media I've never aspired well
you've worked on the media well I
I actually like the media just there
might be a couple but other than that I
enjoy the media I always have and it
can't be that hard no it's not trying to
hire me
well they're hiring you for eye candy I
think that's what it is look at look at
the face oh I know oh don't I know oh
hey uh safe travels there and uh it'll
probably be radio that way yes yes yeah
I made a career out of it uh coach uh
safe travels
and that would be his wife in the
background giggling